Due to the sharp fall in oil prices,
Venezuela is plunged into an
economic crisis with severe lack of
inflation, the situation becomes
a humanitarian and also a political crisis.
President Nicolás Maduro,
elected in 2013, lost his majority in the
legislative elections in December, a
great  progress for the opposition coalition
table for democratic unity after years
of demonstrations the european parliament
has received representatives of this
opposition objective to promote dialogue
the most important thing is to avoid a
conflict of powers that
totally blocks exit from the country the exit
has to  Being democratic has to
be through mutual respect for the
powers and through a dialogue that
allows for agreements. The Democratic Unity Roundtable
was among the three
finalists for the 2015 Sakharov Prize
for freedom of thought and has come to
Strasbourg to ask for support.  of the
european union any initiative that the
european parliament
but  Hugo has to tell the Venezuelan government that
Venezuela's problems must be addressed, which is not
interference. According to this wife of the political prisoner,
the first step to achieve
democracy would be an amnesty and
reconciliation law. The European Parliament gives
priority to diplomacy and dialogue
in  place of economic sanctions